the joke is out here you know well this
is where the wagon broke down and dad
didn't have enough money to get us on
West for hours from anywhere in the
heart of America's breadbasket is a city
for fighting for better
to see the future of america Modelo
looks not to its coast but to its heart
it's there where we found a place that
proves it doesn't matter where you come
from
it matters what you're made of the
people out here have an attitude of
working if you want to work hard this is
the area to do it in I moved out here 30
years ago with not much more than a
shirt on my back then the families out
here took me and my family and we're all
transplants everybody in garden cities
from someplace else the reason why I
came to United States is divide this
back home I was 13 years old you know
and I've seen a lot of bad stuff
happening I see people getting killed
you know since the first day I got here
I feel free I'm from Somalia back in my
country it was a lot of simple world go
alone and just going the town and are
you scared to get hurt something you
know I'm here and I decided to be here
for my life so I wanna have more people
or communities different you know making
big change in city I've seen my family
back in Somalia I wanna have my family
come with me there's no way I can forget
about it when you start with no money
it is tough you know to come to
different town you don't know what's
going on sometimes it might be far but
not impossible
a galaxy is a good proof the piece you
can do it to be a successful person
current city is home it doesn't matter
who you are or where you come from the
doors are open tenemos un poquito de
todo para todos para ser lo mejor y y
ser lo mejor que somos those in currency
people are people we all have the same
wants and needs garden city is
constantly fighting for better and I
think if people just can see that we're
all just trying to have to make it in
this world it's just a lot easier to be
accepting what does it do we die
[Music]